que responsabilidade fechar um ted né
ainda mais depois do almoço já vi gente
dormindo mas tudo bem minha virada de
ano de 2017 para 2018 foi exatamente
onde a maioria dos empreendedores de
eventos como esse empreendedor de
inovação criatividade e mandaram eu ir
desde que tinha 16 anos alguém sabe não
é possível senão isto impede vale do
silício considerado o mais inovador do
mundo né
depois de sete anos ouvindo vai pro vale
do silício munique foi para o vale do
silício e apesar de terem vendido que
apenas uma boa ideia é gerar um bom
negócio e com um bom negócio
provavelmente eu consegui um bom
investidor no vale do silício estou
muito aliviada por não ter acreditado né
até porque a gente não estava na mesma
página talvez minhas referências e
bagagens são outros ea gente não tava na
mesma página
na mesma página fiquei dois meses no
vale do silício e na hora que eu volto a
primeira coisa que eu vou separar bem
bonito que o mérito é seu preferido
aí eu fiquei pensando é também não vale
considerar uma frase como essa porque
pessoas que começam começa ou termina
uma frase com mérito
provavelmente vive ou no conto de fadas
que se chama privilégio não sei se vocês
sabem ou não conhece nenhum retrovisor
da história do país qual vive então a
segunda lívio também não acreditei e não
peguei pra mim essa parabenização mas
prisão de vale do silício quando cheguei
lá eu queria pelo menos encontrar
aquelas inovações e tendências básicas
da vida sabe não aquelas não aquelas que
a gente pega alguma coisa já existentes
e coloca o nome em inglês
tipo o livro que poderia continuar
república o morar junto ou food troque
que poderia continuar carrinho de
cachorro quente da tia do colégio não é
essa até porque apenas 3% dos
brasileiros fala inglês fluente
já quem fala de futuro inclusive a gente
precisa falar português né
não essas mas pensando assim já que
falei básicas com a criação vai é uma
tendência básica colaboração
o até conexão mas também queria entender
neste vale do silício algumas inovações
que tivesse atrelada ao mercado de
trabalho no futuro do trabalho avançando
no mercado de trabalho que a gente faz
vou tirar nossos empregos mas como é que
esses unicórnios ainda continuam
reproduzido modelo fordista do século 20
apesar de colocar por uma nova ótica do
capitalismo
vou dar um exemplo muito prático e
talvez aconteça no brasil e com vocês
desculpa por exemplo quando se olha no
espelho a gente não se reconhecem mais
com o nosso nome falou na nossa empresa
ou trabalha 24 horas por dia e acha que
é incrível em títulos o comum sucesso
ou coloca a pessoa jurídica na frente da
pessoa física esquece que a gente existe
mas como não encontrei nada disso no
vale do silício foi para o vale do
silêncio ler-se periferias rodeios
periferias do brasil tentando mapear
inovações e lá encontrei a cocriação a
partir do momento que a iniciativa de
admite alternativa e cultura
não sei se vocês conhecem de brasília
teimosa e do pina totó suas periferias
de recife começaram a fazer ou então a
colaboração entre três gerações entre a
mãe-de-santo ativista e intelectual do
alto de olinda conseguiu reunir na
comunidade para criar um game chamado
conto de fadas ou até mesmo quando ele
está falando agora de falar onde bitkom
e sintex e afins a maior transformação
digital econômico e social de um a
fintech localizada na favela da maré que
a maioria de nós não quer entrar porque
a gente tem medo mas marielly vive
então pensando nisso e rodando ainda as
periferias do brasil que foram 15
cidades
eu percebi que esse gênio de startup
todo mundo tá grandes gênios maravilhosa
que criam suas idéias na garagem na
califórnia que todo mundo tem acesso tem
tempo para criar uma startup e criar um
unicórnio e uma garagem
nesse momento do brasil principalmente
eu entendi que essas pessoas não
conseguem visualizar esses territórios
do vale do silêncio como inovação porque
a primeira coisa que a gente fala quando
tem algum tipo de inovação é colocar
outro nome que
gambiarra reparem vale do silício é
inovação e periferia sempre relacionado
a gambiarra
mas se é para resolver algum problema
isso também é inovação mas eu acho que
deve haver algum medo por isso que eles
continuam pegando os nossos termos
nossas criações e colocando em inglês
provavelmente ou então criando digamos
utilizando como desculpa o termo
proatividade pra colocar a gente dentro
de uma caixa do faz tudo ganhar menos e
trabalhar mais e nem flexibilidade em
trabalho a 60 horas está dizendo que é
inovador e continua fazendo a máquina né
só que agora perdeu no um botão agora
considerando considerando que essas
profissões como ciência da computação
engenharias e afins estão suscetíveis
automoção acredito que está caminhando
por um momento que precisamos de
pensamento crítico e competências
emocionais ciências humanas para que
chegamos até esse futuro que a gente não
sabe que pode ser que espero que seja
inclusive diante do que eu estou falando
aqui mas o prefeito já tem um pensamento
crítico é a qualidade de sócio
emocionais e ciências humanas
o vale do silício está preocupado com
essa parte da automoção porque
provavelmente as pessoas que vivem lá e
continua nesses unicórnios se assemelham
às máquinas fazendo os comandos do
trabalho 24 horas por dia e não percebem
ea gente não tem esse olhar também para
a periferia fazendo o que a gente acha
que vai acontecer no futuro a periferia
já está fazendo talvez seja esse o medo
de não entender a inovação e sim
gambiarras
mas vale considerar que nesse vale do
silêncio que são as periferias
talvez nenhuma inovação e nada que eu
citei até agora possa ser escalável
exponencial ou qualquer outra coisa que
vocês queiram chamar isso porque o vale
do silêncio grita 500 anos sabe pensar
no brasil 500 anos trazer 50 escravidão
cento e noventa dias sem marielly três
anos da chacina do cabula 45 anos de
ditadura 25 anos da chacina da
candelária
aí está gritando o tempo todo só que as
pessoas não estão vindo e coloca outros
nomes para copiar as nossas criações e
anula a nossa existência
por isso talvez não seja escaláveis mas
a gente vai continuar idolatrando
enaltecendo e legitimando empresas como
não vou citar nomes mas a maior empresa
de táxi que não possui nenhum veículo e
o maior provedor de hospedagem que não
possuir nenhum imóvel
mesmo sabendo que esses dois grandes
empresas e unicórnios da vida continua
produzindo racismo machismo misogenia
xenofobia e mais agora será que o vale
do silêncio está para gambiarras assim
como vale do silício está para inovações
se você respondeu sim realmente não
estamos na mesma página
desde meus 16 anos e provavelmente se
ted não vai servir de nada apenas para
compartilhar nas redes sociais
obrigada e se vocês entenderem e sua mãe
de l
[Aplausos]